ces images témoignent de la violence du
choc peu avant 15h cet après midi un
automobiliste franchi les barrières de
ce passage à niveau à saint martin le
beau arrivant de vierzon une locomotive
transportant des matériaux le heurte de
plein fouet avant de s'arrêter cinq
cents mètres plus loin à l'intérieur de
la voiture un homme d'origine portugaise
âgé d'une cinquantaine d'années habitant
la commune meurt sur le coup
il ya un plus tôt pour tirer des
conclusions définitives mais des
éléments qu'on a donc visiblement là le
conducteur du véhicule s'est engagé sur
le passage à niveau
alors que les barrières étaient
vraisemblablement blessé et donc a été
percuté par l'hôtellerie qui arrive car
effectivement des vérifications ont été
faites et rien n'indique que le passage
à niveau auraient été forcées le trafic
en revanche à lui été lourdement
perturbé une bonne partie de l'après
midi on a bien évidemment le coupé les
deux voies de circulation pour pouvoir
permettre déjà au relevage de du
véhicule qui est sur les voies et puis
aussi aux vérifications qui sont
nécessaires sur la qualité de la voix la
signalisation et puis aussi
l'alimentation caténaire donc on a tous
la formation à mettre en oeuvre
art bouclé pour pouvoir libérer la voie
pour qui sa création se fasse
correctement dès 17h des bus avaient été
mises en place pour transporter les
usagers du ter de la ligne tours vierzon
les agents de la sncf étaient quant à
eux à pied d'oeuvre pour réparer un
câble de frein de la locomotive
endommagée par le choc
le trafic ferroviaire a repris vers 18
heures